[Musique]
salut tout le monde bienvenue sur mon
live stream aujourd'hui je détruis un
robot première étape
[Applaudissements]
ça a marché
ah ben non ça n'a pas trop marché en
fait derrière ses machines et vous vous
demandez encore où est l'argent du
contribuable à moi de jouer vas-y prend
le volant
j'ai mis le régulateur j'ai trop
l'impression d'être une case fc sacré la
famille tôt solic le film le tout
février au cinéma voici lille d'où je
viens
[Musique]
une île paradisiaque plages de sable fin
cascades vertigineuses montagnes russes
à volonté j'ai jamais eu besoin de
prendre le bus pour aller à l'école
parce que je faisais le tour de l'île en
moins de deux secondes toute façon il
n'y avait pas d'école jeu c'est une île
de rêve je vous dit
[Musique]